In the 1930s, the Soviet Union did everything possible
to demonstrate to the world how progressive communist ideas were.
Outside the USSR, articles in the press appeared glorifying Stalin
and his course for collectivisation,
which in reality was forceful integration
of individual households into collective farms.
The articles were written by people like, for example,
the celebrated American journalist Walter Duranty.
However, Ukrainian villagers did not fit into the ideal picture.
They did not want to join collective farms
and voluntarily give away what they had earned.
Resistance was also growing in Ukrainian cities,
among the intelligentsia in particular.
So the Soviet regime decided to break their resistance physically.
In 1932–1933, millions of Ukrainians died.
Rumours of this spread throughout the Soviet Union and abroad.
Even fabricated statistics could not stop them.
Therefore, the Soviet government enabled its propaganda machine
and hid the Holodomor for many decades
behind silence and fake facts that should have been dispelled forever.
However, even after the collapse of the Soviet Union,
Russia, as its successor,
continues to aggressively oppose the recognition of the Holodomor,
using increasingly aggressive methods of propaganda, including outright lies.
Lie #1. There was no Holodomor.
Dozens of villages died of the famine.
And those who survived were forced to keep silent
so as not to incite the members of the NKVD
to pursue their families and friends.
The Soviet government tried all means to limit the leakage of information
and falsified statistics on the number of people killed
by the artificial famine.
Foreigners also contributed to this.
For example, the journalist Duranty described the famine
only as temporary difficulties
that simply had to be endured.
He claimed that there were no deaths in the USSR.
Most foreign diplomats who came to the Soviet Union
did not have access to the real picture or preferred not to notice it.
They were allowed to see only specially created Potemkin villages,
in which, as in theatrical performances,
extras were dressed as villagers, and tables were set.
The topic of the Holodomor was silenced in the Soviet Union until the late 1980s.
However, archival records have been preserved.
Among those documents, there were decrees
and resolutions on food confiscations,
restrictions on movement for Ukrainian villagers,
and a ban on foreign journalists from leaving cities.
Together with the memories of thousands of survivors,
they serve as proof of the crime
committed in 1932–1933 by the Soviet government
with Joseph Stalin at its top.
Lie #2. Poor crops caused the famine.
This lie has long been supported by Soviet historians, who had no idea of ​​the real events of that period.
In fact, the weather conditions in 1932–1933 were favorable,
and the yield was sufficient.
The grain harvest in 1932 was actually  less because fewer seeds had been sown,
so the reason was not the amount of precipitation or atmospheric pressure,
but the ill-considered agricultural policy of the state.
People were dying of famine in the villages of Podillia.
And only 200 meters from there, over the Zbruch River in Poland,
people had enough food.
In addition, in 1932–1933, the USSR rejected
any offers of help from other countries,
and even more, it actively exported grain.
Lie #3. The famine spread throughout the whole USSR.
Many eyewitnesses recall that people in Ukrainian villages suffered
because there was nothing to eat while in neighbouring
Russia and Belarus people had no food problems.
Interestingly that only in the territory of Ukraine and Russian Kuban,
inhabited mainly by Ukrainians,
there was a system of “black boards”, or “boards of infamy”.
It was forbidden to enter and leave villages,
and accordingly, to supply any food.
On 22 January 1933, the Soviet government issued
a resolution banning people from leaving Ukraine and Kuban.
In addition, villagers were deprived of the right to buy train tickets
and barred from entering cities.
It was the territory where the most Ukrainians lived,
and where the mortality rate from the famine was the highest.
This fact proves that the Holodomor was indeed
the policy of the Soviet government against Ukrainians.
Lie #4. Ukrainians did not resist.
In fact, the resistance to collectivisation on the part of Ukrainian villages
was one of the main reasons why they were exterminated by making people starve.
In 1930, one third of all village demonstrations against the Soviet rule
among the republics of the USSR happened in Ukraine.
More than a million people took part in them.
In the same year, activists, grain procurement commissioners, and workers of the State Political Administration
were attacked 2,779 times in Ukrainian villages.
It was one fifth of all such cases across the USSR.
For example, the territory of the Dnipropetrovsk region
in just four months
from October 1932 to January 1933 recorded
7 murders of activists,
10 attempted murders, 5 injuries,
6 cases of beatings of government officials.
Villagers would set fire to state institutions
and collective farm buildings.
They would come to a collective farm building, protest,
and take their cattle and grain back.
Or they would simply refuse to work for nothing
and sabotage the process.
In the conditions of constant searches, in order to survive,
people tried to hide at least some food,
using pits, basements, attics, or burying supplies.
Similarly, in the fall, thousands of people
tried to run away from villages.
However, all these actions did not grow into a mass
consolidated movement.
The remnants of the village resistance were broken
by total physical destruction.
Lie #5. The Holodomor was organised by locals.
Such a myth was advantageous to the Kremlin
to absolve itself of responsibility for the Holodomor of 1932–1933.
It was beneficial for them to say that Ukrainians killed their own people.
In fact, the ruling elite was multinational.
They acted primarily as representatives
of the communist totalitarian regime,
not some ethnic group or nationality,
who carried out orders given from above,
and were part of a single system.
Even so, some officials tried to mitigate the situation in Ukraine,
warning that it was critical and asking
to cut the grain procurement plans.
Instead, the central government
in Moscow refused and tightened its grip,
as evidenced by the archival documents from
the Communist Party conferences and congresses.
Lie #6. There was no mass mortality due to the famine.
In 1926, almost 31.2 million Ukrainians lived in the USSR,
and in 1937, there were only 26.4 million left.
To compare, the number of Russians during this time
increased from 77.8 million to almost 94 million people,
Belarusians — from 4.74 million to 4.87 million people.
In addition, mass graves have been recorded, as evidenced
by thousands of Holodomor eyewitnesses who managed to survive.
These facts prove that entire families and streets died out,
so there should be no doubt that the Holodomor was massive.
Lie #7. We have known everything about the Holodomor for a long time.
Some of the valuable oral testimonies of the Holodomor eyewitnesses have already been lost.
Millions of people who survived those events died.
And most of the documents have not yet been processed,
although the archives of KGB in Ukraine are available to all.
However, the main and most important ones
are still kept secret in Moscow.
Until Russia, the successor to the Soviet Union,
recognises the Holodomor,
this piece of information will remain closed to the world.
Lie #8. The Holodomor was not genocide.
Genocide is an intentional act aimed at physically destroying
an ethnic, national, racial, or religious group.
The policy pursued by the Soviet Union in the territory of Ukraine
was directed precisely against Ukrainians.
No other national group has suffered such losses.
Nowhere, except in the areas where Ukrainians lived compactly,
were such methods used.
The decisions of the top leadership of the USSR,
medical registers, death registers, eyewitnesses’ accounts,
and hundreds of other documents are proving it.
Thus, the Holodomor is genocide of the Ukrainian nation,
and it has been recognised by 17 countries,
including Ukraine.